the wonders yes that thing you do is
turning 25 this year and the film's fab
4 is giving us the reunion that we have
all been waiting for it's a wonderful et
exclusive
when i say
25 years jonathan what's your first
thought it's just mind-boggling i
couldn't wait to meet the rest of the
guys i remember every second of this of
this shoot e.t was on set back in 1996
with tom everett scott jonathan scheck
steve zahn ethan embry and of course tom
hanks who was doing triple duty he wrote
the script directed it and played the
record company exec who tried to make
the one hit wonder rock band famous it's
very important you don't stink today
cut
very good people ask me all the time
how's it going i'm not really sure
entertainment
entertainment tonight what was it like
working with tom anything he said was
like gold
[Music]
tomorrow to celebrate their 25th
anniversary the foursome will reunite in
erie pennsylvania where the movie was
set they'll sing take me out to the ball
game at the sea wolves minor league
baseball game at upmc park all the
proceeds go to a charity corps students
who are have dyslexia and the three
three out of the four of us have
dyslexia love how they're paying it
forward now want a behind-the-scenes
secret the music was all real well
here's what tom actually had to say
about your musical abilities back then
steve zahn did indeed play the guitar
enough ethan embry uh
played some of the bass jonathan shack
he learned in order to play it and the
key of the whole thing i think was tom
everett scott you can't fake the drums
he had never played the drums before
in his life
you can't fake the drums tom everett
scott
no you can't no you can't i was scared
to death i had a good teacher though
ethan you you played before you still
play i still play but gosh i think i was
16 or 17 when we shot that
that song we couldn't get out of our
heads well it became a hit record and
was nominated for an oscar oh and one
perk of knowing tom his then 18 year old
son colin made his feature film debut
wife rita wilson made a cameo as well
she slept with a director
that's it tom also gave big breaks to 19
year old liv tyler and a 21 year old
charlize theron they make a cute couple
huh he's my hero
and it all began with
that thing you do my second movie she
was already way more experienced than i
was i was really like watching her like
what do we do now
bye
[Music]